make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing up and make
sure you guys hit the like button if you
enjoy the video and yeah let's begin
okay so continuing on with our beyond
omega-level series for those of you guys
who are not part of patreon I've
actually started letting my patrons
decide what videos were going to do on
on beyond omega-level so if you guys
want to have your input if you guys want
to contribute to which ones we end up
making head over to patreon check it out
it's like a buck or something like that
I'll post a poll every week based on the
various Akira's I'm going to do and then
say which one of these are you guys the
most interested in and then we just kind
of go from there
but in this week's video we're covering
Proteus now Proteus is a character that
I wouldn't be surprised if we end up
seeing more of in the upcoming x-men
comics because he was revealed to be one
of the five which is a group of mutants
that use their powers to revive dead
x-men on krakoa and Hickman's house in
powers of X so I'd be willing to bet
that Proteus is gonna be a pretty big
part of the x-men stories going forward
and since he's not really one of the
most well known mutants I figure we go
ahead and cover him here so Proteus
originally appeared in uncanny x-men
issue number 125 and he was created by
Chris Claremont and John Byrne although
he had been referenced earlier than that
Proteus is origin is actually pretty
dark in that more McTaggart was
basically assaulted by her husband who
had basically forced her to marry him
and as a result she ends up getting
pregnant with her son Kevin but she
leaves her husband Aereo because of his
abusive nature
and never tells him that she's pregnant
now following this she takes kevin to
her mutant research center on Muir
Island near Scotland but after he starts
exhibiting his mutant powers she
realizes that he's a danger to others
because of the side effect of his powers
being that he has an insatiable hunger
for energy right so like a mini Galactus
basically so more of basically locks her
son in a containment cell where he is
surrounded by a constant supply of
energy and she tries to keep his
existence a secret she's able to do this
essentially for a pretty good chunk of
time until the x-men and magneto end up
in a battle on Muir Island and damaged
the south which allows Kevin to escape
now after this he possesses the body of
a boat captain named Angus mcworter who
is basically a dick try this guy just
didn't like more McTaggart or the x-men
so like after he broke into like this
old boathouse he was trying to basically
dig up dirt so we could kind of expose
them and get him booted out and then
Proteus took over his body now
eventually and not really even
eventually like right off the bat
Proteus realizes that mcquarters body is
not an effective vessel for his power
and so he seeks out a more powerful host
and thinks that he has won in Jean Grey
who was actually in possession of the
Phoenix force at the time and is simply
able to resist Proteus as possession
however he ends up taking over the body
of one of the Duke
it's of jimmy manderach's also known as
a multiple man but Kevin's eventually
get funded by the x-men they end up in a
fight and Proteus pretty much wipes the
floor with all of them and he does it
quite readily like he totally like
decimates the entire x-men team but
ultimately he's scared off when Morra
fires a sniper rifle at him because he's
wonderful in a metal and so Proteus ends
up running off and goes to confront his
father whom he possesses before fighting
with the x-men yet again and this time
when he's in his form of pure energy
he's punched by Colossus which scattered
his energy throughout the world because
once again Proteus is vulnerable to
metal and Colossus has asked me a metal
skin and so while it was thought that
Proteus was dead following this battle
of course we're in the realm of comics
and so his death was anything but
permanent as a Proteus ended up popping
up a few times since that initial
storyline and prior to him showing up in
Hickman's run he was most recently seen
in astonishing x-men when the shadow
king found a piece of his energy
floating around in the astral plane and
used it as a power source to do battle
with Charles Xavier now eventually
Proteus was reconstituted into a
physical form and once again defeated
the x-men who seemingly disperses energy
across the world a second time and we
don't really know what happened to him
that led to him being in Hickman's x-men
books we're not really sure how he got
there all we simply know is that he's
there but we'll probably get an
explanation as we get deeper into this
run but onto Proteus has powers which is
what you guys are here for right you
guys want to see that you guys want to
talk about like the powers of Proteus
and what it is that he's capable of he's
able to consume the psionic energy of
others possess and inhabit their bodies
and even warp reality he typically
exists in the form of pure psychic
energy and when he possesses the bodies
of others he's able to access their
memories and carry them with him
whenever he leaves their bodies now in
Proteus possesses a body he drained them
of their life energy so they can only
last for a very limited amount of time
before he burns them out entirely and
they're discarded many Proteus has to
constantly find new house and according
to Jean Grey after she probed his mind
he becomes increasingly powerful with
each new body that he possesses now
after one of his resurrections he was
able to possess more than one body at a
time indicating that his psionic
abilities had actually grown since his
initial appearance when he only
demonstrated inability to possess one
body at a time in addition to possessing
others he can also create force fields
blasts of psychokinetic energy and
teleport others into his mind as a
Proteus has also demonstrated some
telepathic ability as well as resistance
to the telepathic abilities of others
now because Proteus is made of pure
energy he has
an insanely high level of durability he
was unfazed by a lightning attack from
storm and survived a combined blast of
cyclopses optic beams and havoc spies
mah blast this is an insane amount of
power that's basically coming out of
there now even taking into consideration
his weakness to metal even if Proteus is
killed he's able to reconstitute himself
after being dispersed making his death
temporary and rendering him effectively
immortal now Proteus also has
reality-warping abilities but they are
more limited than some of the more
powerful reality wars in the Marvel
Universe like Franklin Richards and Jim
Jasper's because Proteus can only warp
what he can see and focus on if he loses
concentration whatever he's warped will
revert back into its normal state now
even with that limitation in mind we
have seen Proteus uses powers in
multiple times to change one object into
something else or to neutralize the
powers of his opponent in more than one
instance Proteus has used his
reality-warping abilities to nearly kill
his opponents such as turning the iron
in Magneto's blood into lead causing Ice
Man to melt and draining the power from
rote so again this is an insane amount
of power here right I mean it's not
every day that you see stuff like this
this is the reason why I say when it
comes to reality workers no matter what
scale they're on in terms of like how
far-reaching their abilities are for the
most part they're all pretty much at the
top of my list right now remember when
it comes to reality warping there really
is no limit to this and that's the
reason why Jonathan Hickman put Proteus
on his list will make a level Mutants is
because if you can warp reality in a
localized space you could work reality
on a universal space it's just a matter
of how far you can push those powers and
how much you can see and how much you
can enhance your abilities because the
reality is that anybody who has reality
warping powers friend Richard's Jim
Jasper's whatever the case is they've
all basically got cosmic awareness right
the ability to understand what's going
on on a cosmic level the question is can
they tap into it and can their mind
handle it usually when it comes to
cosmic awareness it's kind of handled in
a couple different ways and he takes
somebody like Wendel Vaughn who's given
the quantum bands and suddenly gains
cosmic awareness it could be
overwhelming
of course his mind was basically capable
enough that he could handle it but you
give it to like any average Joe we're
under any normal circumstance it can put
him into a catatonic state we saw that
when the Phoenix basically gave jason
wyngarde cosmic awareness for a brief
moment in time showed him everything in
existence and his mind shut down he
couldn't handle it right so how Marvel
does it is contextual it's based on the
story and how it is they want to boost
the character whether they want to do
anything with him or whether
leave them alone or whatever the case is
but more often than not with somebody
like Proteus to gain true cosmic
awareness he would have to take it in
steps right because it's mines already
unstable so he'd have to take it in
steps right you have to become aware of
everything in the solar system and then
maybe everything in like 20% of the
galaxy and then everything in 50%
working his way up to a hundred and then
everything beyond that sort of taking it
in phase is a kind of expanding out bit
by bit over time to the point where he
can basically achieve cosmic awareness
and know everything that's going on
throughout the entirety of the universe
once that happens Proteus will be
insanely powerful he'll be an AI
omnipotent unstoppable being within the
confines of the universe he'll still be
weaker than like like eternity or like
the Living Tribunal or somebody like
that but at the moment he's just
basically a guy have to manipulate
reality in a localized space so at the
moment we know that he's basically Omega
level right like we know that he's using
his powers to resurrect x-men after they
die as part of the New World Order of
mutants the Charles Xavier is
establishing on Kirk OA but I think that
personally it'll be pretty interesting
to see what kind of well he's gonna play
in the future stories of the x-men and
going forward but with that being said
guys we're gonna bring this video to an
end if you are new here to comics
explain make sure you guys at the sub
button to become part of the Rob core if
you guys enjoyed this video make sure
you drop a like again if you want to be
able to vote on what videos we're going
to have make sure you head over patreon
and make sure that you take part in that
whole voting process right it's not
super expensive it's not like I'm not
gonna charge like 20 bucks a month to
vote on characters for beyond Omega
level that's stupid and I'd be stupid to
expect you to pay that it's like a buck
or something like that also for those of
you guys who are unfamiliar I do have a
personal Instagram at I am Rob Jefferson
we just crossed 10,000 followers
yesterday and I think we're at 10,000
600 now we're growing really really
really really fast that's really awesome
on so make sure you guys head over there
because I'm actually giving away Rob for
rings starting on November 4th running
to the November 8th one rod port ring
each day there's there's a catch to it
there's actually a video on there that
will explain how the rob four rings are
given away once November 8 ends I'm
gonna take that video down so that I'm
not having people who show up in
December you know believing that they're
gonna get a rob forming I don't want to
I don't want to lead people on like that
ah but yeah it's it's cool like I think
you guys are really enjoy but yeah guys
we're gonna go ahead and ring this video
to an end
and I will catch you all later peace
[Music]